Advances in technology
are always met
with some degree of
technophobia and villainization.
From the very beginning,
mechanization has been
perceived as a promise
and a threat.
Talk of humans being
replaced by machines
immediately emerged
alongside voices praising
their life-enhancing benefits.
Cyborgs are a unique
amalgamation of both ideas
since they directly
merge flesh with tech.
Some of pop culture's most
iconic villains are cyborgs,
but so are some of the heroes.
What is it about the
blending of man and machine
that scares us but
also thrills us?
[exciting orchestral music]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is Monstrum.
The impact of industrialization
and mechanization are crucial
to the cyborg's history,
but that's not where
the idea began.
We have to go way back.
Stories of human
automatons date back
as far as the fourth
or fifth century BCE.
The Chinese philosophical
texts "Liezi"
includes mention of a play
that utilized a mechanical
puppet made from wood
and leather that could
independently move its head,
sing, and dance.
Records of steam-powered
human-like automatons
appear in the text of
Alexandrian engineers in Egypt
around the Third Century CE.
There are also tales
of automated soldiers
protecting relics in
ancient Indian Buddhist texts.
In both fiction and real life,
automatons were
intriguing rarities
prized for their unusualness
and ability to inspire wonder.
And yes, obviously cyborgs
are different from automatons,
but the two have a
blended cultural history.
A cyborg is a living
organism machine hybrid
while an automaton is
a machine made to look
and or act human.
Legends of brazen heads,
bronze or brass talking
fortune telling automations
modeled after humans
fill the pages
and stages of the
Renaissance period.
First appearing in
the 12th century text
"Chronicle of the
Kings of England,"
they were often said to
be powered by the devil,
sorcery, or necromancy.
So these disembodied heads
were viewed as monstrous,
defying natural order
and challenging the
idea of the soul
by raising questions about
what moved our own bodies,
what imbued life in a thing.
In the 17th century,
French philosopher and
mathematician Rene Descartes
introduced the
beast-machine hypothesis,
theorizing that the
human body is composed
of mechanical
processes or motions.
As medicine emerged as
a profession around this time,
so did the understanding of
the body as an organic machine
supporting Descartes' theory.
Of course, this overlaps with
the Industrial Revolution
and political revolutions
across the world.
In science and culture,
the concept of the body
was becoming destabilized
at the same time
the manufacturing process
shifted from human hands
to mechanized devices.
New technologies like the
battery, the steam engine,
and later, electricity,
opened a world of possibilities,
including artificial life.
While the emergent technologies
became increasingly
linked to imagination,
magic, and utopia,
they were also met with
fear and trepidation.
It wasn't until the 19th century
that the first human-machine
hybrids appear in fiction.
Technically,
German Gothic author
E.T.A. Hoffmann's
1814 "Automata"
has the first
quasi-human automation,
but everyone knows
it's a machine.
In his 1816 story "The Sandman,"
two men attempt to pass off
a wooden clockwork-driven
automaton as a real woman
with moderate success.
Jane Loudon's futuristic
1827 novel "The Mummy"
includes speculative
technologies
like a mirror holoscreen,
flying robotic horses,
and labor androids in the
form of prison guards,
judges, and lawyers.
In these texts before
and after their non-human
identities are revealed,
these creations are viewed with
a mix of revulsion and awe.
Seen as unnatural
and frightening,
these Romantic era androids
reflected
the cultural conceptions
of the human-machine dynamic.
Edgar Allen Poe
famously explored
the boundaries of
the mechanical body
and the human body in
his science fiction.
During his writing career,
the United States saw over
3,000 miles of train tracks
laid across the US,
with both the medical doctor
and machine doctor or mechanic
emerging as professions.
All of this likely inspired
his 1839 short story
"The Man That Was Used Up,"
which is widely cited as the
first true cyborg narrative.
The tale is a satirical
social mystery of sorts.
A narrator tries to
determine the story
behind General
John A.B.C. Smith's
great notoriety as a war hero.
Formidable and handsome,
the narrator is
horrified to learn
that the general he admires
so much lost his teeth,
arms, legs, scalp,
shoulder, chest, and eye,
and most of his tongue from
torture while a war prisoner,
and now uses a false
eye, wig, cork legs,
and other man-made parts,
including a mechanical tongue.
When the narrator
sees him without his
non-organic additions
as a large and exceedingly odd
looking bundle of something,
he's frightened into
shocked silence.
So we've had humans with
machine enhancements
in fiction for a
couple hundred years,
but it took until 1960 for
someone to define them.
The word cyborg
first appears in 1960
in a New York Times
article about scientists
looking into
enhancing astronauts
for space travel efficiency.
Coined by researchers
Manfred E. Clynes
and Dr. Nathan S. Kline,
the article proposes development
of human-and-then-some bodies
that would not need
to eat or breathe
because of battery powered
devices built into the body.
They provide us with the first
public definition of cyborg,
essentially a man-machine system
in which the control
mechanisms of the human portion
are modified externally by
drugs or regulatory devices
so that the being can
live in an environment
different from the normal one.
The late 1970s and '80s
were a time of cultural
and social technological
pandemonium.
The introduction of
personal computers,
portable phones, fiber optics,
and of course, the internet
challenged our worldview
and created new anxieties.
In a post-industrial world,
existing fears of machines
taking over humans' jobs
and relevance seemed
even more possible.
And like always,
popular culture
exposes that anxiety
and imagines the possible
effects of digital technology,
positive and negative,
in dystopian android movies
like "The Terminator"
and "Blade Runner,"
but also more
optimistic characters
like the superhero Cyborg
in DC Comic Universe
and "Ghost in the Shell's"
crime-fighting cyberpunk
Major Motoko Kusanagi.
In 1985, Donna Haraway's
feminist post-human text,
"A Cyborg Manifesto,"
declared we are all
already cyborgs.
She argues that
humans are chimeras
of organism and machine,
a reality
we sit with uncomfortably,
although she argues
we should take pleasure
in such instability
and transgression.
Haraway uses the
cyborg as a metaphor
to challenge the definition
of human and non-human.
She points out that
we are already cyborgs.
Modern medicine has
advanced to the point
that small machines
can reside in the body
in what she refers
to as couplings.
The anxiety around cyborgs
is their perceived threat
to humanity in
the physical and mental,
enhanced humans who challenge
the very idea of human.
Post-humanism is
a philosophical concept
that challenges
anthropocentrism,
the idea that humans
are the central
and most significant
entities in the world.
It's all about blurring or
eliminating the boundaries
between humans and other
organic and inorganic matter.
Monsters and the
post-human are intertwined.
As N. Katherine Hayles argues
in "How We Became Post-Human,"
even the threat of
transformation via technology
inspires simultaneous
terror and pleasure.
But that does not
mean that post-human
has to be apocalyptic
or anti-human,
but you can probably
see how the cyborg
can easily represent
both the negative
and positive interpretations
of post-humanism.
Discoveries in zoology
also contribute
to our modern
conception of cyborgs.
By the end of the 20th century,
the distinction between
the human animal
and the non-human
animal is narrowed.
Many non-human animals
craft and use tools,
problem solve,
have complex languages,
social behaviors,
and grieving practices.
The cyborg then is
a man-made distinction
between human
and non-human animal
where artificial devices
contribute to making
humans less animal.
Although a more radical approach
is to see the cyborg as a
break in the distinction
between human,
animal, and machine,
in a post-humanist
utopian vision
of connectivity among all things
where boundaries
are not only blurred
but they also
simply don't exist,
which is both liberating
and terrifying.
This is why the cyborg
is always made monstrous.
From the hive-mind driven
villainous Borg in Star Trek
to Marvel's Dr. Octopus
or James Bond's
nefarious Dr. No,
evil or antagonistic cyborgs
are physically threatening
with their divergent
technologies
marking them as the other
or the bad guy in the story.
Even when cyborgs
are the good guys,
this holds true,
but they are painted
in a different light.
Robocop, Ironman,
Major Motoko, the Bionic Woman,
and others like them
almost always have some
traumatic backstory
or event that propels them
towards mechanical augmentation,
justifying their monstrosity.
Star Wars is the
perfect example.
Both Darth Vader and Luke
Skywalker are cyborgs,
at least since the
end of Episode Five.
We spend "A New Hope" and
"The Empire Strikes Back"
following Luke's
struggles and triumphs.
His tragic backstory,
an orphan relegated
to a hard life
on an unforgiving planet
after his father was murdered,
at least that's what
Obiwan tells him,
creates sympathy even
before his hand is cut off.
Luke's artificial hand even
looks organic at first.
Essentially, his cyborg
nature can be hidden.
Darth Vader's tech,
on the other hand,
is not only on full display,
it visually makes
him the villain.
His cyborgness isn't justified.
That is, not until
Anakin's own tragic history
which helped push him to choose
the dark side is revealed.
I must point out that this
only happens explicitly
in the newer movies
released at the turn of
the 21st century when arguably,
attitudes towards robotics
have somewhat shifted.
Nevertheless, all cyborgs
still represent the fear
inherent in losing ourselves
in the technologies we create.
Cyborgs may not
inherently be monsters,
but we are afraid they
will become monsters.
Our response to them is
largely driven, I think,
by how we want to integrate
technology into our life.
Do we live with technology
or do we become technology?
"Liezi." Did I do it right?
Sliezi includes mention--
(crew)
Hold on.
Clockwork-driven ato,
the automata, automaton.